foreign  I think that that's what it takes to be  successful is just like giving it  everything and putting everything on you  know you have to give into it for the  last 14 years Justin has been putting  everything he's got into it  [Music]  now the Canadian is estimated to be  worth  285 million dollars  honest Forbes estimates that when Bieber  is on tour he makes an estimated 1  million per night that means he's  bringing in an eight-figure Revenue  during each tour  when he's got down time Bieber is  kissing wife Haley while road tripping  through Utah and you guessed it kissing  while in Hawaii  the Bieber brand is big business it's  reported that in 2021 Justin could  collect around 700 000 for a sponsored  Instagram post and while how much he  received for his collab with Tim Hortons  hasn't been released it's safe to assume  it's in the six figures Bieber is making  bank  I like it  [Music]